Mary what's going on.
BILL BYRNE It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday May 15th 2017
halfway through the month of May.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Do you know Bobby or scored that fuckin
overtime goal on Mother's Day to win the
Stanley Cup.
Back then.
You know I think you only had to win
eight it was like fucking 12 teams.
He had the original six and the expansion
six the original six really weren't
the original six they were just a six
leftover after fucking the stock market
crash some shit they were the only guys
left after World War 1 I can't remember
didn't like the Lusitania sank and then
the like half the players on the fuckin
Montreal Maroons were on it I don't know
what is it stumped a fucking Swami over
here.
He has been banned she's been recording
the sports Jeopardy a.k.a.
Buffalo Wild Wings Jeopardy.
I would tell you a sports fan it's not
easy but oh do I seem like a smarty when
I'm watching that show to the point and
here goes if they ever do any sort of
fuckin you know comedian
sports jeopardy thing or you can give
the money to a charity I love that shit
it's like I'm going to go on TV on to a
game show one of the hardest game shows
out there Jeopardy granted it's all gonna
be about sports but they do a lot of
shit of like you know you know who is the
first free agent to fucking get into a
fight with Al Davis and say I don't
fucking know right name the last three
owners of the Seattle Seahawks like they
could they take it to that level you
know what I mean
but I love our needs like I know you
should go on then just you know give the
money to a charity fuck the charity and
do enough benefits as a comedian I can't
go on TV to try to win some money for me
you know in a couple of categories
they're gone Well you know
I'm going to go on TV and expose
how limited my fucking I don't my world
is I don't know Gummer go on TV and make
an ass of myself and then give it to
some dirty faced kid afterwards I'm gonna
lose.
Then what.
Some kid who grew up in a fucking chimney
is gonna sit there crying because I
went there and basically did the Babe
Ruth thing a kid I've got then hit a
homerun for you today Sep I'll do it
with my mind man they're not going to go
out there and I'm gonna fucking lose
because they're going to be like yeah what
brand of baseball glove.
Goose Gossage use when he was still on
the fucking Oakland A's Rawlings Oh no
sorry the correct answer was a Wilson
douchebag family with the chance to steal.
I actually did.
You know if I can remember the category
my problem with those shows is sometimes
like I don't understand the
they'll say like Get Carter and it takes
like me like fucking three in a row to
understand like oh these are everybody's
got the last thing Carter I've got the
hardest one too.
Or maybe I'm just the oldest they
brought up the fuckin dude on Michigan.
Then I think went to the fucking USFL
make this fucking Anthony car number one.
I first started watching college football
he was the man out there with the
Wolverines All right.
Bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah.
That Doug a great fuckin fight songs of
all time the Michigan Wolverines dat dat
dat dat dat dat dat.
I'm fucking with you.
I know where it goes.
Hail to figurative value.
And I was singing the Notre Dame song
Oh Jesus this team made Oh Jesus.
They're gone for a two
point conversion there.
Jesus. But you gotta say well you
know I mean they make. They make it.
I mean I love everybody get out of this
fucking locker room you bearded hippie.
That's what happened of Jesus came back.
Jesus ever went to the locker room
and Newt Rockne was in there right.
Oh five foot nothing of them
considered fucking average height.
Way back in the day before they put the
horse tranquilizers in the fucking horse
meat that they fed to the horses that
they then fed to the cows. Right.
That then in my burger.
Maybe that's why I have such a fucking
disposition. I eat a lot of red meat.
There's so much red meat I
I don't consider hamburger
red meat to me red meat as
I had a steak.
I have a burger I mean it's it's
it's not it's not red
after I'm done cooking it.
No actually it's not even true.
I like I like all of it medium rare
and what I've been told by a cool life
freaks where they're like look
you can have a steak medium rare.
That's a lot less of a risk
because that's just one cup.
You know you're rolling the dice it's
like you're bang one hooker without
wearing a glove.
Jesus Bill right.
And then hamburger though
it's like a bank Vietnam.
Line pig Vietnam.
For some reason I went to fuckin full
metal jacket Hey baby you gotta go for
Vietnam.
It's like you banged a
fuckin country at that.
That's what hamburger is because it's
just a bunch of cows all fucking mulched
together. Right. You have a steak
it's like you just fucked one cow.
That's what I'm trying to steer
I should say. What's the stare.
Well it's a bull without his balls buddy.
Right.
Take off its fucking horns.
I don't know what it is anyways and if
you have hamburger that's like you know
you know you're just Freddie
Mercury running around
fucking the whole free world.
Isn't that basically it.
I mean I'm not you know I'm not I don't
know my way around the kitchen enough to
know if that analogy worked
or not but I will say that I.
Let's just get back to
the original point okay.
What was the original point. Yeah.
I don't consider hamburger red meat.
Or was it that I'm not given some
fucking kid who lives in a chimney.
I don't know why a chimney.
You know.
You know seeing broke children is
always sad unless they're white.
There's just something fucking funny
about you know I think it's just a relief
as a white person that the
guilt goes away. You don't know.
You know anytime you see somebody from
another race broke you know white people
fucking pushed them out they
put a Wal-Mart down right.
They put one of those derricks in there
they started sucking all the fuckin shit
out of it.
You know I wonder if people around the
world when they watched the beginning of
the Beverly Hillbillies start crying you
know when they just see the white man
even THEY FIRST THEY LAUGH LIKE OH MY
GOD IT'S toothless broke white people
hilarious and even they discover
oil and they get to keep it.
So they loaded up the drug and
moved to Beverly Hills that is.
I wonder if they cry
when the children cry.
You know nobody gets the
movie I was talking about.
I kept references.
We had problems with the family back east.
Anyway speaking of the children and
cry that's from white line everybody.
When the children cry was actually a hit.
That's how fucking off
the rails music went.
At one point
little jab jab. Yay. Yay yay yay.
Now it's like on the top 10.
I remember watching it.
I didn't give a fuck about that song but
I was like that lead guitarist of all
these fucking guys trying
to be Eddie Van Halen.
I'm not saying this guy was trying
to do the shit that Eddie did.
That fucking guy white line.
He came the closest you know out of all
the white bands you know the white lines
the fucking know who else was it was
white lion Great White who's white snake
it was Hey there Whitey.
It was a little known all white funk
band because that's what people used to
yell when they would say I care
about how cos I don't know.
Anyway speaking of children crying
my condolences to all the fans of the
Washington Capitals.
And you know what happens when you hit
the fucking wall for the third time when
you win the president's trophy.
You know under two
different presidents OK.
When Obama brings you to it Donald Trump
comes in with his tie hanging all the
way down to his tie would still touch
the ground even if he was wearing skates.
He goes walking into a locker room
and he gives you that fuckin trophy.
Yeah you're on your
second goddamn president
you've left the ugliest uniforms in the
history of the fucking game a hockey
possibly definitely up there.
Those blue ones with
that gold fucking eagle.
You know it just looked like they put a
stamp like them like the post office had
a limited stamp thing you know.
Then all those weird fuckin smelly people
you know people don't bathe collect
stamps you know and I'm not saying that
you know with all this stuff like what
do you identify with a man or
a women you know being a man.
I don't I am a man but I don't identify.
Stone identify when he mentioned the
fucking emptiness of that every day waking
up shave going What the fuck is this.
I can't relate to this
fucking beard on my face man.
You know when am I tits gonna come in.
I just I can't imagine that but whenever
there's other people that can't you
know they don't identify
with other human beings.
Forget about they don't
identify with their own gender.
There's another group of people that
we all need to care about and wear a
certain color on a certain
day or maybe a ribbon for.
And these are people that can identify
with other people they just can't
identify with human beings in general
and these people collect stamps you know
they just sit in their room they're not
bothering anybody taken that big giant
fucking book off that shelf.
You know blowing the dust off it.
Because they finally got the Washington
Capitals fucking horrific jersey from
the mid to early 2000s whenever they
had that it was an awful period.
That's why in the NHL
they added too many fucking teams and
everybody changed their uniforms I should
put it all on the capitals Washington D.C.
fucking horrific.
Thank God they went back to the
red white and blue. You know.
I mean you are there
in DC for fuck's sake.
You know if anybody shed the color
of the flags should be you guys.
You know the Buffalo Sabres.
That fucking HL horse shit they had you
know where they put a sheep on the front
even a bull anymore I was
terrible fucking terrible.
Props to them by the way when they
finally admitted that they made a fucking
mess there was such a horrible period
they had that strike that they lost a
whole season of the NHL All right.
They added a bunch of fucking teams too
many goddamn teams they had the Atlanta
Thrashers they had the
fucking Florida Marlins right.
That's right.
They played hockey first before they
suck so bad they were like you know let's
just fucking play baseball.
Now if the Florida Panthers.
The lightning the Coyotes
I think the North Stars moved down to
become the stars at least they kept the
kind of air there all right.
Because they kept the same
fucking uniforms and of
course they knocked down that
stadium in Minnesota.
They put up the Mall of America they're.
So sad. You know the place where Dina's
sister really smashed his stick over that
fucking guy's head.
You can now sit there standing there
eating frozen yogurt without a care in the
world. You know. It was that road game.
Anyways
the fuck am I talking about.
That's right.
So then you had all these new teams in
the NHL and then on top of that all these
teams that had been established
all changed their fucking uniforms.
So you come back after the strike and
you just watch and like Dude is this the
fucking Olympics.
Well actually that's not true because
after they started doing that in the 90s.
Because when the Sabres the
Sabres got fucked in 1999.
You know back when you could even have
a fucking shoelace tough like fucking
shoe leather that would sort out huh.
Who knows that one.
There's another obscure tough like
fucking shoe leather that mozzarella.
Woods around. Whatever the fuck you
said mozzarella. Who knows that.
If you're religious you might
know that that's a hint.
The title has something religious
a religious figure in it.
And it's not Jesus Christ Superstar.
That's the last hint I'm gonna give you.
The other savers got fucking nineteen
ninety nine. Was it Brett Hall.
Was it fuckin.
Danny mash Byrne I don't
know who the fuck it was.
Joe Berry Carol who had their foot in
the fucking crease I can't remember but
the whole year they're calling it until
the biggest goal of the year the one
that decides the Stanley Cup Classic NHL
yeah their new rule that's been fucking
everybody all year round.
Yeah forget it.
We've decided to change the rule in
overtime in the clinching game of the
Stanley Cup playoffs. That's
how we do it. That's right.
That's how we do it.
We take breaks every 20 minutes and we
have rules and all of a sudden the rules
go away.
So anyways my condolences to the city to
the District of Columbia capital fans.
Man they fuck identity again.
You know and you keep showing up because
you're real fans and yeah it's gonna
suck now they're gonna dismantle
the entire fucking team.
Hopefully they keep a Vatican.
You guys are out of your fuckin minds if
you get rid him are they gonna blame it
all on him. Did you see that picture
of his leg. I'll fuckin bruised up
he looks like somebody's trying
to get information out of him.
He wouldn't give it up you know.
Fuckin veins sticking out.
I thought his crane in there.
Jesus Christ.
I feel like a bad Dabney is in there
okay. He is handling it. Don't worry.
Can you hear that.
Yeah.
This is the time a night like she's so
like wants to know everything that's
going on that she does.
She won't nap enough during the day and
by the way fuck all your suggestions.
I don't wanna hear a million suggestions
put one of her shirts in in the bath
and that we've tried everything OK.
It's just you know it's a phase she's
going through and I am done listening to
fucking people who are
not wearing lab coats.
If you're not a lab coat on and you don't
have a fucking little degree hanging
on a wall behind you just keep
your fucking ideas to yourself OK.
The level of shit that parents talk every
fucking one of them has a goddamn cure
for every fucking thing that happens
every one of them just glided through
fucking being a parent.
I've figured it all out and
for some stupid reason they
didn't cash in on it and
write a book.
Why would you do that when you can just
show up to somebodies house and vomit
all your fucking ideas on.
If any of your people's fuckin ideas work
you should put it in a book and go on
the Oprah channel and you guys can sit
there holding each other's fucking hands
as she tells you how
amazing you are said it.
Come on over here boring me with
it and then I go and try it.
You know actually you know what the
shirt one worked the shirt when did work.
I will say that I should have fucking
said that because a relative suggested to
me and it was fucking great. That's just
the first thing that popped in my head.
I was actually thinking about somebody
else that annoyed the shit out of me was
something else trying to feed my kids
solid food. Three months into her life.
No it's fine it's fine.
This is this is the danger riffing
because you end up shitting on the person
you're not upset with
anyways plowing ahead.
Where am I. Oh yeah. Condolences.
You know so I would definitely
keep Ovechkin you've got
to build around the guy
build around the guy again and you know
get a coach with a neck and you know you
know maybe you can see if something was
offsides or not and you can you could
throw the flag or whatever you do to
challenge it instead of sitting there with
his spine fused.
Somebody made the joke said that every
coach in the NFL in the NHL looks like a
Bond villain.
And it is true.
I got to go with that.
You know what I mean.
Although I would say that Claude Julien
Claude Julien looks like that that dude
in the swamp thing that when he got turned
into a monster became that little guy
running around
such a weird fuckin movie where I don't
even remember the name of the movie the
whole thing about the movie was there
was this chick and she had these giant
fucking tits and you just waiting
for it to go into the lake.
So they'd show a little side boob.
Now this is the early 80s.
That was a big fucking thing
when you were like 12 years old.
All right.
So the deal with the Swamp Thing which
is where I got that thing I had problems
with the family back east
that's that's where it's from.
It's from the swamp thing.
I'm obviously fucking with you.
When I talk about the swamp thing.
Right. So how that worked. He was.
He was I forget what hand the
guy was walking near a swamp.
You know the usual thing and then a
telephone pole falls into the fuckin swamp
he gets electrocuted and then he becomes
the Swamp Thing and he's as strong as
shit and there's some fuckin bad guy.
So they figure out how he became the
Swamp Thing so then the bad guy wants.
He wants a Swamp Thing
of an army a swamp thing.
So whatever he can take over
all those swamps. I don't I
don't remember. Right. So.
This fucking little weaselly dude he does
the same thing and when he turns into
a monster he's as little
as fuckin weaselly monster.
So then the bad guy goes well how come
we didn't turn into what you are and it
says well you know when
you get electrocuted in the
swamp and you turn into a
swamp thing it just
enhances your personality.
All right.
So if you're a fuckin stud like me who
even know I look like a swamp thing I
could still bang that big tits
whore over there in the lake.
If you're a little weaselly can't you
just become an ugly weaselly cunt with
like mud and leaves for skin.
There you go people I.
And I can't think of a bet sorry
just blew out your is there.
I can't think of a better time to
read a little bit of advertising.
What do you say there. What do
you say then. What do we got here.
Oh wait I got to finish so you know
what I could say to DC fans is when you
finally fucking win it it
makes it all the sweeter.
Just going through all of this shit all
right I watched the Bruins from about
seventy nine eighty eight
a week to late 2011.
So what's that a 9 9 9 2009 I
watched them for about 33 years.
All right.
And I know you go woo woo woo woo woo woo.
Shut up.
All right you got all those monuments
she could fucking walk around kids you.
Cheer up.
Look at the weather the Wizards forced
the game seven I'll talk about that a
little later after I read a couple
of fuckin advertiser minutes here.
He likes everybody he likes your unique
Oh you're a special little fucking cunt
aren't you.
You don't walk like everyone else talk
like everyone else sleep show chat.
Like anyone else.
Let me ask you this why is your
mattress one size fits all.
I hate this question just because there's
a general hate that people are from a
little baby all the way up to like if
you make a mattress that fits somebody
about six foot for your cover and like
babies all the way to like 90 percent of
adults it has to be right.
I don't know what do I
know about mattresses.
About as much as I know about reading out
loud but I'm going to continue because
a truly customized mattress will
cost you five to ten thousand bucks.
Until now.
Go to Helix Sleep dot.com.
Answer a few simple questions and they'll
run a 3D biomechanical model of your
body through the proprietary algorithms
they've developed with the help of the
world's leading ergonomic
biomechanics experts.
The results of fucking robots
shows up to your front door.
Looks exactly like you with a
mattress strapped to his back.
He gives you the URL for fucking Sheva
and next thing you know he's banging your
wife on the bed that you paid for.
Sorry.
Now what really happens is the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept on
shows up right.
Your lady lays in and she's like
Oh my God this is great right.
She reaches over for your fuckin meat
hammer and next thing you know you need to
buy a new mattress.
He likes customers report a 30 percent
improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples they customize
each side of the mattress.
The beginning of the end of your marriage
is when you have the customer telling
you that's the beginning end of it.
That starts with that.
And then he goes you know it'd be great
if your tits were a little bit bigger
right and then she starts redoing herself
like Matt Damon in the Liberace movie
and then one day just gets rid of her.
Maybe nowadays with millennials
it probably goes the
opposite way the way these
broads a slap and the guys around
in the shows now it's unbelievable.
Hanging them off of fucking balconies
and stuff your mattress arrives at your
door in about a week and
shipping is 100 percent free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about like sleep.
That's what they're doing.
They're not talking about ties.
They're not talking about the
next hostile takeover right.
They're talking about mattresses.
You have 100 nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it they'll pick
it up for free Gross and give you a 100
percent refund no questions asked.
Go to Helix Slate dot com slash burn get
50 dollars off your order that's Helix
Sleep dot com slash per head
Helix Sleep dot com slash br.
Here we go.
Me on D but only Bono
both me and D me on D.
Look at that fuckin robot doo doo doo
doo me on d me on D is balls of metal
don't say they're not.
He walks up your door slams You in the
face fucks your wife doesn't care about
race cause it's metal not so nice and
soft and then he lays down on a helix
mattress and bang your sister all right
elevate your underwear a game to the
next level with me on this.
You've perfected your wardrobe but what
about the stuff not everybody gets to
see we're talking about your
junk everybody it's time
you braided your pubes oh
wait this is the wrong copy if you've
been settling for Staub underwear five
packs I have something that will change
your life for the better it's me on this
what's the first thing you put on
and the last thing you take off.
Oh it's not your socks it's not your
contacts it's your fucking drawers it's
your underwear make your most important
piece of clothing the best it can be
with me on this follow up colon what
is beyond these are just seriously sore
feel good undies delivered right to
your fucking door read colon by why I'm
gonna read all of this shit
Myanmar's are designed in L.A.
that's either Los Angeles or Louisiana
and made from sustainably sourced micro
model of fabric three times softer than
cotton and then you know what I believe
it now because I haven't cotton hasn't
said a fucking word about it and I've
been saying this for years Myanmar is
softer than soft luxury undies come in an
ever changing selection of classic colors
bold shapes and adventurous patterns.
Ventura's patterns what are the outline
your dick on it so you can tailor your
undies to your own personal style and
guess what you can save time and money
each month with a monthly subscription
and if you're not ready for a
subscription that's OK man you can
still save no pressure you mean.
That's because me is offering you 20
percent off your first pair just use our
special you are ell me undies dot com
slash BA and get 20 percent off your first
pair so go ahead revamp your underwear
drawer you deserve it your coke once
again that's me on this dot com slash BA
beyond these dot com slash BRR How many
more of these fuckin
things are they all right.
Dollar Shave Club do Dollar Shave Club
is this smarter choice you'll get a great
shave at a great price conveniently
delivered right to your door you no longer
have to schlep to the store to buy a
cheap disposable razor that gave you a
cheap shave or spend a fortune on razors
with gimmicky shave tech technology you
don't need and when you use dollar
shave Club's Executive razor with their
doctor Kaveh shave
the blade just gently glides giving
you a smooth shave Dr. cabbies shaved
bladder talked to cavities easy shave
but of his I call it is transparent for a
more precise shave it's transparent
and visible like the flames that burned
Ricky Bobby helps prevent ingrown
hairs and fights razor bumps.
Look at that.
Make the smart choice by joining
Dollar Shave Club for a limited time.
New members can get their first month
of the executive razor with a tube but
their doctor
but only five dollars with free shipping.
After that razor has
just a few bucks a month.
That's a 15 dollar value
for only five bucks.
There are no hidden fees no commitments
cancel anytime you like it's a one night
stand but with a razor you can only get
this offer exclusively a Dollar Shave
Club dot com slash burn that's
Dollar Shave Club dot com slash burn.
I don't know if you guys noticed but I've
gotten much better at reading out loud.
You know.
Watch this.
I'm going to say right now I bet I only
make three mistakes in the next two
fucking reads.
You want to bet what you want to bet.
You want to bet a little
calves easy shea butter.
I bet you have fucking
a handful of that shit.
All right.
Policy genius all right.
I never said how fast or slow I'd go.
Life insurance.
Do you have it.
See that nail that first sentence.
If not why.
Too expensive or a hassle man.
If you don't have life insurance what
would happen financially if something
happened to the primary earner.
What are you talking to the wife here.
God knows the primary earners that is the
man. And that's not a sexist statement.
I'm just saying I'm just I'm just a
progressive male and I've listened to all
these women bitch moaning and complaining
that we all make more money to do the
exact same job.
But wait a minute how many women are
plumbers and then Mary a plumber.
I'd be the worst.
You're all fucking competitive
both going to bed smelling
like fucking shit and wrenches.
All right.
Let's keep going here.
Life insurance is a good idea to protect
the ones around you but where do you go
to get the best prices or the best policy
with the best service policy genius
policy genius has a very simple user
friendly website to shop and compare all
the top rated life insurance companies
and give you the best options while
you're there check out their other
insurance offerings like pet insurance
PET INSURANCE FOR WHAT
CASE YOU FUCKIN fish reverse drowned
when it flops out of the fuckin tank.
I guess for dogs get their fucking teeth.
Got a policy genius dot com today and
save over 40 percent off prices for life
insurance when life insurance soars
compete for your business you save money.
Is that a job while life insurance.
Ah there's the first mistake that was
gonna get an eagle on this fucking hole.
That's policy genius p o l i see y g e
and i u s that's the second mistake I
fucked up on the dot com please spell
it out I just did zero jargon zero sales
pressure fuck amount of mistakes I still
got one more to go zero hassle life
insurance made easy free quotes I got
the yips zero hassle peace of mind don't
wait got a policy genius dot
com today all right. Ho ho
ho ho ho ho.
Believe me I got one more year.
Oh no I don't.
That was the last one.
Oh this is this guy giving me shit about
airline bumping Oh he fucking went off
on me he fucking put me in his place
when he sat down at his goddamn keyboard
I'll get to this in a minute I will get
to this in a minute I like this guy who
gives me shit about the
airline bumping you know why.
Because it's very few people out
there that defend the man all right.
Anybody can attack the man every once
in a while it takes a fucking fucking I
don't know the internet version of that
Clint Eastwood spaghetti western guy
coming to town with his little fucking
Mike Tyson's colorful Mike Tyson towel
over his fucking head right.
That's all broke Mike Tyson was when
he was a boy he first started up.
He was like I want to dress like Clint
Eastwood they said Oh we'll get you his
underwear his boots and we'll get that
little fucking that little shawl he puts
over it but you know we can't
afford to put any color on it
you know and that's the kind of thing
that lead you to bite somebody's ear off.
I'm just saying I'm not trying to say
that what he did was right but I'm just
saying I understand.
Hey how you doing up there in
Montreal everybody Montreal Canada.
How's things going up there.
Enjoying the fucking off season.
God knows you're gonna have enough
time to come and see me in June.
This is what I'm loving about
the predators. All right.
Although they seem like
they're losing right now.
I'm taping the game but I'll fuck I'll
fuck myself over here and I'll just look
it up right now.
Oh look at that the little time trial I
think you're going to fuckin load for me.
I think the ducks were up 5 to 2 or 5 to
3 how fucking weird Are these playoffs
this year.
You know.
Anyways you know I always give you guys
shit about the curse of Patrick wow you
humiliated that guy.
I mean what you guys did to him when
you watched like like horror movies.
You know what I mean when somebody like
you know thinks they're prom queen and
then you dump a bunch of blood on them
or they think that they're gonna go make
a wish in a well and then their
mother pushes him to the bottom of it.
Yeah I mean they think that you
know that that all of that shit.
All of that shit right.
Somebody drowns in a fucking lake.
You guys did the hockey version
of that to Patrick what. You know.
He thought you guys loved him.
That's what it was like Kerry.
He came out there you know has one
fucking bad game you won't pull him.
You'll leave him in there you fucking
do a mock cheer when this guy who
redefined the position
first ballot Hall of Famer continuing
the tradition of winning fuckin Stanley
Cups.
You know when he won it during the real
era when there was like 30 fucking teams
28 teams not all those cups the Canadians
and Maple Leafs won back in the day
when it was him the state was
like a fucking shot glass.
Seems skate around with the
thing looks like a fucking baton.
You know before it became
that giant god damn thing.
Anyways they booed him out of town.
So ever since then there's been
the curse of Patrick White.
And I think the next fucking part
the next chapter of the curse.
Okay is P.K. Sue Bowen. You know.
You know what they they ran him out of
Falconetti ran that guy out of town.
Now this wasn't your fans.
I think it was the organization.
I also think it's
because I'm a Bruins fan.
I just love giving you guys shit
because when I'm gone I do talk about
championships you guys
are gonna destroy me.
So this is this little fucking little
thorn I can put in the underneath your
fuckin elephant foot here.
All right.
What P.K.
was a fucking great dude and he gave too
much money that children's hospital he
started becoming bigger than the Canadians
and the Canadians couldn't fucking
handle it.
Like when Kobe couldn't handle Shaq and
he said looky there he goes awry go.
And they said OK Kobe and they sent
Shaq to Miami and then he won a fucking
title there right.
Then they had to bring Phil Jackson back
and another fifty fucking free agents.
As they always fucking do.
You know I you know I just give Kobe
shit for the first the first three rings
Get the fuck out.
The last two I'll give you those.
You know even with the officiating and
that second time you played this Celtics
Hey let's call fucking 38 fouls
on one team in 17 on the other.
That's that makes for a
good game 7 doesn't it.
Not saying that we would've won but it
would've been nice to see the Lakers beat
the salt except you're just saying
anyways plowing ahead so now the
predators are up 1 did nothing against the
fucking Emilio Estevez as the Sheens
whenever the fucking column down there.
The mighty the mighty Sheens
the Anaheim s devils is the mighty ducks.
I don't like the ducks
I don't like ducks I.
Don't give a fuck. I just don't like
them. Okay I don't like the Honda Center.
OK I you go there there's no fucking vibe
there's no vibe in Anaheim it's just a
fucking it's just I don't know what it is.
It's just a strange god damn place.
Anaheim is fucking weird
his whole fucking L.A. areas weird like
people weren't supposed to live here.
You don't know me.
They weren't supposed to fucking live
here it's a fucking desert we still water.
Hold all things weird but at least
you know this is cool shit to look at.
You know except when you go to Anaheim I
don't know what you look at. All right.
And you go down there there's no
fuckin vibe. Maybe it's better.
I went to a ducks game in the late 90s.
They were still early right.
They were still the Mighty Ducks they
still had Donald Duck with the broken bill
on the front isn't what they had
for their logo. I don't know.
So anyways what if what if what if.
P.K.
leads the Nashville Predators.
To a Stanley Cup championship this year
I'm just throwing that out there for
everybody up there and St.
Catherine Street with your cute little
pocket squares that matches the color of
your socks.
You know what the fuck are you going
to do that Nashville that banjo playing
fuckin washboard down by the fucking
river. Ever been to Nashville.
I mean have the structures
there still have dirt floors.
It's unforgettable. It's
ridiculous. You know
like when they went this day when
they went to Nashville this year.
And they were like you know who
you voted for for president.
They were like I'll tell
you one thing I blanking.
You aren't afraid to fly.
That's how backward naturalists you know
I know there's all this shit out there
saying it's this growing city you know
and they're trying to get people to move
there.
The reason why they're trying to do that
is because so many of the structures
still have dirt floors.
Okay now if he can go down there right
and and fucking lead them to the Stanley
Cup the big boy Stanley Cup and have
their little shot glass that you want you
would fucking Toronto one like
fucking 15 times each. You know.
I'll give the Canadians their last 10
cups but I look at them like I came to say
they're equal Detroit because Detroit
was back then when it was a shock less.
You know sort of fancy shot glass.
Anyways
I'm just fucking with you.
I have no idea how the fuckin predators
were in the finals the Western
Conference finals with the ducks
and then the Ottawa Senators.
What the fuck is going on with that when
it when is when is the glass slipper
going to turn back into a fucking punkin.
I'm telling you.
If Ottawa goes any deeper
into the playoffs they're
actually going to sell out a
home game.
Midseason believe.
Did you see the first game of the Rangers
they had two thousand of the Rangers
three they had two thousand empty seats.
That's because they stopped playing
the Bruins. You know what I mean.
And the Bruins were just close enough to
Ottawa that that shuttle flight wasn't
it wasn't too expensive you know.
Then they played the Rangers
and God knows Rangers fans.
All those fuckin Manhattan cunts.
They got the money to fly up to Ottawa.
But then New Yorkers. Do what.
Why would they get bored.
They got a slice of cheese.
Why would I travel.
Look over there at the
Empire State Building. Oh.
That's what New Yorkers are there.
They're fucking they like country people.
You don't have to be lonely fucking
Skanks in the fucking five boroughs.
I am in an extra country mood and I am
just trashing people that I have no right
to trash. OK. My team
is not in the playoffs.
Ok my team has not won as many
championships as the fucking Canadians.
My city doesn't have as many
skyscrapers in New York City.
They don't fuck with my city.
You just fuck with the wrong city.
I probably would barely back east.
If you touch my family
I'll fucking kill you.
Those lines will never
get old in Hollywood.
You know it's another fucking hacky thing.
I'm so sick of every other fucking show
doing this speed dating fuckin scene.
How many times can you do that in
one fucking lunatic after an Emmy.
It's not that bad.
Jesus fucking Christ people showing up
with like half an axe in their side of
their head.
People live with their mother the person
who's actually gay pretending to be
straight to fucking say me mean Eddie
Murphy did this shit fucking and then
coming to America in 1989.
Jesus Christ why do you just have somebody
come in and slip on a banana peel and
then get a pie in their face
and then do the dating thing.
Hey Bill you so talented won't
you come up with something new.
Because I limit it.
All right.
I never said I fucking
would reinvent something.
All right unfortunately I have to take
a little bit of break and I'm on a nice
little roll here.
I'm on a nice little roll here but I
have a go I get some I gotta take care.
Which is why I'm doing this
at 9 o'clock on a Sunday.
But why do I need to tell you guys because
it's going to be a fucking second of
your life.
All right hang on hang on a moment.
OK I'm back.
I'm back and I am as illiterate as ever.
You want to this is somebody just
fuckin tearing me a new one here.
So I was talking about fucking United
Airlines and Delta and then just yanking
people off of flights and like
what happened to customer service.
And all of this type.
You know I felt guilty flying United
the way they just drag that Chinese dude
off the plane to go into China
just as so many was Chinese Asian.
Give me that right. Who knows. Who
knows. I'm so fucking hard I don't know.
You know fucking
fuck me anyways.
Airline bumping he said.
He says hey you uninformed cunt.
Well I'll tell you.
Nothing makes the reader want to read
more when you just start off with the
insults he said Congress and the
passengers bill of rights have led to more
passengers getting bumped
due to more cancellations.
And do you think he gives any examples.
Now he just moves on to his next point.
Also if people showed up for the flights
they booked the airlines wouldn't be
overbooked.
Many passengers book multiple flights.
How about if you buy.
So you're just assuming that the guys
that are yanking off the flights to those
people.
I don't do that.
I buy one fucking ticket nice show up.
That's how I do it.
So you're telling me that that Chinese
dude or that other fucking person on
Delta you're telling me that that those
are those people so they say you book
like 20 flight she only
showed up for one day.
Get out of fuck I said get out of there.
You're telling me that's what happened.
Or are you telling me that
because other people do that.
Because the guilty people did it that
United and Delta is now just going to grab
some random innocent person and
throw them off the fuckin flight.
I heard the reason why they did it was
because they had another plane that they
had to get a flight crew to and they
just fucking yanked the guy off.
That has nothing to do with that
other shit. As far as I know.
But I hate what am I am
just an uninformed cunt.
Evidently you who just like me just
make statements with no fucking evidence
behind it. All right.
Plowing ahead he goes.
How about if I buy a ticket for a flight
and miss it for whatever reason you
lose it.
Question mark.
Is that how you run your shows.
Was that a point.
How about if I buy a ticket for a
flight and miss it for whatever reason.
Karma you lose it.
Oh how about if you have
a problem with that.
I don't have a fucking problem with
that at all. I'm on the same page.
I hate when I show up on time for the
security line and somebody else shows up
super late and then they get rewarded
and get breezed through the fucking line
like they're in that team like they're
part of the TSA party they're the pre
check people.
You're bringing up all this other shit
that has nothing to do with a fucking
just somebody who bought a
ticket and sits on the plane.
I drive a car.
Other people steal cars should I be
yanked out of my fucking car because other
people are stealing cars.
This makes no sense.
I might be an uninformed cunt but you
are a pompous arrogant uninformed cunt.
I could say that because I'm
in show business. You know
we're all down to earth.
Alright let me read some more of your
air quote points. All right. Is that I.
Is that how you run your shows.
No I don't run my shows like that.
You know this is my fault.
Here's how I run my fucking show.
I don't have anybody kicked out ever.
You can be the biggest Conte ever.
I kicked the first fuckin
person out in 10 years.
Because he was so fucking drunk I'm
a hell of a guy. I don't give a fuck.
I'm a great guy when it comes to that
shit how dare you love me and with United
Airlines and Delta.
Ew ew ew ew hateful so and so.
All right. Let me please finish this point
here. Is that how you run your shows.
Or if someone buys a ticket to your show
and misses it due to traffic leaving
the house late etc. Do you honor
their ticket to the next show.
I will tell you this I've had plenty of
people fuck and reach out to me and I
have hooked plenty of
people up with tickets.
OK how about that.
Has everyone reached out to me
has ever seen every fucking email.
No but I hope people up.
I've run into fucking people walking down
the street drive by a occasional Fuck
you.
To go to show.
And I'm like it's all soda faggot fucker.
What's your name.
I've done that countless times.
So there you go sir.
I don't know you talking about
all the equipment to that is I fucking
pull up and stand outside the gates of
the airport.
Hey you guys flying in Minneapolis.
Yes sir we are. Could I.
Can I buy a ticket. Sorry.
It's all sold out.
Berman I don't worry about it.
Don't worry we'll get you on the plane
and then they fucking yank someone that
they yank somebody off.
I don't know why they
picked the Asian guy.
Huh.
Why couldn't they pick some fuckin
white dude in a suit. You know why.
You know why. All right. Leave
the house late in the game.
Well that is what the airlines
do if you miss a flight.
They put you on another one.
So fuck off you non reading pigment
impaired that's not what they do.
That's what they do sometimes.
Other times they yank you off the plane.
Other times it Taylor go fuck yourself.
Other times they say hey you have to
win a thousand miles you can't use them
when you want to use them.
And if you don't use them by next
Wednesday we're taking them all back other
times they say hey which is charging
extra because it's post 9/11 we lost all
this money which is charging for food but
eventually will fuckin stop overcharge
and we'll stop charging for this shit
for all the money that we lost in 9/11
which you know we're now going to
pass on to our fucking customers.
So they take the hit one was fucking 9/11.
I know I'm an uninformed cunt as far
as my calculation were coming up on the
16th anniversary this September. You're
still paying for Pringles aren't you.
Sir I'm all for defending the fuckin man.
When it's when it's for I mean I don't
I don't know what you just fucking.
You just brought up a bunch of.
I guess behavior by frequent flyer people
so then evidently I should get yanked
off a plane at some point because other
people overbook and shit you don't you
you're the kind of person
that probably likes that Dad.
Well they call it a trap ride.
The trick car whatever that fucking
show is you probably like that show.
You probably think that that's
a good fucking show right.
That show I came to believe that
fucking show is on television.
It's on Tru TV.
We should change the name the fucking
horrific TV they fucking think they drive
down to like the fucking projects and
they leave a car with the door open keys
in it running and then they wait for
someone to fucking steal it and then they
act like they've got a bad
guy off the fucking street.
And I was reading comments underneath
that you know I love it they're going to
go out of their fuckin way.
To go down there and try to get someone
to go to jail what do you go down there
and try to help somebody out.
I saw one guy.
He actually stole the fucking car.
He knew it was the trap car whatever he's
driving with the door open because he
knows that they just like the big
fucking hit the locks he can't get out.
And he's saying he knows his strap
carries waving to the camera all that.
They ask if he knows a trap car why did
you do it he said I don't know maybe I
just want to get on TV and then he laughed
and everybody's like that goes crazy.
I want wanna party with that guy.
That guy's a dope or anything.
It was it was to me it was
fucking depressing. Like that.
That's the level of options this
guy has in his fucking life.
He would do something like that. Somebody
else brought up a great point. OK.
Like why don't they take that car around
the fuckin suburbs to the White cul de
sacs why don't they do that.
Maybe a book will go.
Kids don't steal the fuck they don't.
They absolutely do and I'll tell
you there's a point my fucking life.
I would have done that.
I absolutely would have done that just
for this stupid fucking just to have the
story so I could talk about it loudly
around chicks that I liked because I
didn't know any other way to approach him.
If they ever did that in a fucking suburb
in a bunch of white kids started going
to jail over that shit that shit
would not would be entrapment.
It wouldn't be held up in court and
the fucking show would be shut down.
All I'm saying. Okay. You sir.
You probably like that type of
shit you probably like that show.
You think that's a good show and hey
let's let's you know rather than giving
this guy an opportunity you know they
could just as easily controlled TV have a
fucking show where they go down and
they try to give somebody a fucking job.
You know.
Anyways plowing ahead making
your own baby food a Billy burp.
Had my first kid a couple years ago.
Congratulations.
A friend suggested we make our own baby
food because it's easier to get them to
transition to real and healthy foods.
We tried it and it was fun.
Friends suggest that we make our own
baby food because it's easier to get them
to transition. Okay all right. We
could hey there's another fun guy.
No lab coat no degree.
We couldn't do it 100 percent of
the time but was totally worth it.
My kid isn't that picky of an eater
and I like to think think that days of
pulverizing fruits vegetables and oats
into tasty meals. Oh it's because of that.
I'm sure you can afford the good stuff
for the little lady but just thought I'd
throw it out there.
Thanks.
Go fuck yourself. Yeah. I don't
know. I don't know what to tell you.
I'll cross that fucking robotic everybody
is always like you got all these
goddamn suggestions it was somebody
fucking you know everybody talking about
like private schools
versus public schools.
It's like these fucking kids
they only get to be kids anymore.
They should be fucking you know
this whole fucking thing that you know
from day one like it gets gotta be like
you've seen what it does
in these countries that and
push their kids too hard.
They have like all serrated fucking balls
like they've been working on fucking
Wall Street for 60 goddamn
years and in like 7.
The level of stress that they put on
I'm fucked that my kid's going to be a
goddamn kid.
All right I flunked everything fucking
in high school I fucked up everything I
got a restaurant drinking and driving.
I was unloading trucks
I did all of this shit.
Then one day I just figure out what
the fuck do I what do I want to do.
I found a passion and I
followed it and I was fine.
And I remember back in the day they used
to fuck all you need two years of the
language if you know to use of a fucking
language you can't level it's all
fucking bull you know it's to say
that the fucking language teacher fuck
everybody
fuck everybody like you could be a god
damn kid and fuck all these fucking
private schools within nine
zillion dollar fucking you know.
Oh you better get in when the kids are
just playing with blocks the early you
get in the better chance you
have your kid to continue on.
In other words start fucking
line in our pockets now.
Yeah why don't you just have no.
Won't it be cheaper to just
have your kid homeschooled.
Drop all that fucking cash like
he's already going to Yale.
And then fucking going to school then
go on the wheels on the bus go round and
round round there and that'll be enough.
Yeah.
The credit card didn't work.
Yeah I can't teach the
rest of the song All right.
Birthday boat party.
A bill.
Your bald headed eagle.
Jesus.
Going fucking old school on that one.
Hey you Chesler.
Hey yes Sidewinder.
Recently my girlfriend dumped
me over a text message.
I swear to God if that if that existed
back in the day I would I would fucking
be lighting phones up if
that wasn't bad enough.
I got the text just as I was
walking into a movie with a buddy.
She told me straight that
she didn't love me anymore.
I took it like a man watched the movie
went home and cried like a bitch.
An honest guy. Two days later
I went to a party on a boat.
I spotted my now ex.
We made eye contact and she looked away.
So now I'm trapped on
a boat for four hours.
You didn't know that she was gonna
be there with a bunch of drunk cunts.
I don't want to be around and of course
her I made an attempt to ask her why the
fuck she had the balls to dump me face
to face but she ignored me totally.
She's young and immature.
I then saw her walk over to a guy
and start kissing him. Jesus Christ.
I commend you sir for not
throwing yourself in them.
Also overboard a fucking double murder
slash suicide Bill I have no fucking idea
I didn't punch this cunt
but I decided not to.
I now wish I had punched
his stupid fucking face and
my question is what should
I have should I have done
something fucked now.
Why are you punching him.
He's doing what he's supposed to be doing.
He's supposed to be out there
trying to fucking a couple women.
All right. Any bad feeling you
have should be towards her.
But here's the thing dude.
You know in the long run she did you a
favor because she didn't love you okay.
And eventually she could have done that
while you had two kids with her and you
actually had to pay her fucking money.
She did you a favor all right.
Yeah.
Don't ever do that.
That's the dumbest shit ever when people
fucking date somebody and then they get
dumped and then they're
fucking dating somebody else.
I mean and then you go over and you
confront the other fucking party.
They're outside the circle.
You know so
what should he have done.
You should just been a fucking gentleman.
That's what you should've done.
You just be a fucking gentleman just
feel like you know evidently you know she
doesn't want to be with me anymore.
I mean dude I know this and I got dumped
I know fucking hard this is a one time.
I actually fucking was talking to somebody
hard on the table this woman dumped
me out of fucking nowhere and I'm in a
bar of course and I'm talking to a buddy
of mine and.
The problem was he got dumped like 4
years earlier and he still wasn't over it
and he fucking hated women.
So this is one point my heart out to and
as you know I mean I thought everything
was going fine with the fight and I did
all that shit and he just goes hey you
know I don't know maybe she
want to fuck somebody else.
And I just said you know what.
I said you know fuck you I actually
flipped out like Fuck you you.
That has nothing to fucking do with this.
That has to do with that fucking shit
that fucking cunt you dated for fucking
years ago.
He is still not over and I've been having
a fucking carry you off the field like
Kellen Winslow after that fucking overtime
game for lack of every fucking bar
for less for you. You can't sit there.
He's like Do Alonso's egg of fuck off.
That's just part of a bad memory.
Actually did I say that.
That's what I said on the way home.
I think I said that on the way home.
I think I just said fuck you when I
walked out of the bar. That's right.
That's what happened. That's
how old I am. I'm so old.
My memories the fantasy that.
My memory is what I should have said.
I didn't say Fuck you and I walked down
as a guy and I just fuckin walked out.
One of the few times I didn't pay for my
round of beers I was just like Fuck you
walked out. Anyways she said Hope
you're well thanks and go fuck yourself.
Do you took it like a man.
What are you gonna do. And.
You know keep taking it like a man and
keep going home and private and cry it
out here. That's what women do. Fucking.
They cry it out of them and then they
can move on the fact that she dumped you
and then of course is immediately making
out with this guy is really suspect but
you never know with them.
You never know.
That could've just.
She could've just picked that guy.
Because you were there.
You have no fucking idea.
And here's the thing dude even if she
was already banging that fuckin douche
while making out with that douche
when she was with you then that's the.
That's who you were with. So
good fucking riddance. All right.
That's what you had.
You thought you drafted somebody in the
first round that didn't fucking work out.
And you know what that guy just picked
up her contract for you you know.
So now you've got all this cap space.
All right go crier out of
your fucking heart you know.
But don't go around hating women.
That's what I did. Big fucking mistake.
All that does is stop you from meeting
the fuckin sweetheart because you know
who loves an angry woman
hater a fuckin psycho chick.
All right there you go.
All right.
Russian girlfriend a belly blue balls.
Hey man I was. Hey man I was wondering
if you could give me some advice.
I'm a 27 year old from New Zealand and
current resident and current Jesus and
current currently residing is what you
should say instead of current residing
here. Current resident
here current residing here.
Okay I've met and recently
started dating a girl from Russia.
We've been officially dating
for about five months now.
Everything is going great.
Never been happier if she ever
asked you to take a boat ride.
Don't get on the fuckin boat all right.
And I'm not talking about
because of the last thing.
All right this when you show up does a
couple of the shifty guys there and then
your identity gets stolen and we never
see you again. All right. She's hot.
Best in bed I've ever had
and I've had a lot haha.
Got a great personality and someone I
could see going further into the future
with. Okay well you're writing me so I
know the other shoe is going to drop.
The only issue is that our visa is about
to run out in a few months before she
moves back.
Unless we can she can
find a decent job here.
The only issue with that.
Is the job market over here for the
type of work she is after is very small.
A translator.
We've been checking the job sites and
whatnot over the past month with not much
luck.
So I've put up the idea of maybe heading
over to Russia and trying to start a
life over there. Oh no. Fuck no.
But that's a great way to see if she's
with you because she wants to be with you.
My qualification can take me anywhere
in the world but I'm still skeptical on
most I just uplift my whole life and move
to a country that doesn't really speak
much English apparently with my girlfriend
that I've only known for a few months
plus not knowing much Russia.
Yeah.
Plus you don't know how
that country fucking works.
All right. You have no idea how
that fucking country works dude.
You're talking like you're
dealing with the fuckin mob.
Hang on one second.
All right sorry.
I just realized I double booked myself
and a fucking Vegas somehow. Yeah.
Dude you have no idea what's
going on over there like.
That's a whole different
fucking animal over there.
That's a whole different government.
The level of influence that the mob has.
I mean that shit is fucking hardcore
over there. Russia is no joke.
What the fuck did you
say you were coming from.
You've gone from New Zealand to Russia.
You give the Guard name. Fuck that dude.
Fuck that.
Fuck that fuck that.
Get her a job interview they'll see
how beautiful she is and you know that.
You know do what you can fucking do.
To fuck that.
Fuck that.
Repeat fuck that. I mean I don't know
and I've been reading the rest of this.
Fuck that do not move from
fucking New Zealand to Russia.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Do not do that please don't do that.
OK.
I never beg in the podcast but I'm begging
you right now do not fucking do that.
Jesus.
You can go from the fuckin Garden of
Eden to that now you're the immigrant.
Now she's trying to get you a fucking job.
You know kind of money you're gonna
make over there. I'm gonna fuckin IDF.
Fuck that.
All right.
Soccer coach rips off
shirt after rejection.
Hey Billy dad SEC.
That was as original as
Billy bald eagle was.
Not that I saw this video and thought
it might interest you during a recent
soccer game an Argentinean player
accidentally knocks a player out from the
other team and ends up getting ejected
from the game as a result after he gets
ejected the coach freaks out. Yeah I
watch the clip starts yelling at the refs.
Then he gets ejected.
So when he realizes that he's also ejected
he rips his shirt off only to reveal
he's an older guy too you know.
I don't know.
I can't tell older guys somewhere between
40 and 50 rips his shirt off only to
reveal that not only is this dude fucking
shredded but also his whole back is
covered in tattoos.
Making him look like he spends his free
time going to bare knuckle brawling down
by the shipyard. Thanks for all the
laughs and go fuck yourself. Yeah.
I watched the clip of this.
This guy looks like.
This guy looks like he's
done some time in prison.
What's amazing is the rest of his body
that you can see he has no tattoos.
And then on the back it's just like I
don't know what the fuck he's got going on
but his entire back is covered
and it's all of those you know.
You know if he touch my family
I will fucking kill you.
It's those kinds of tattoos.
It's not the I was in a frat
and I got drunk one night and.
All right this is my old girlfriend's
name and we fucking turned it into a swan
or whatever the fuck they do.
This is like hardcore you know this
guy is gonna punch you in the throat.
It's a great clip.
I really appreciate it.
And then make sure I did everything here.
Russian girlfriend Do not stay in
New Zealand. Birthday boat party.
Yep you got a lot of cap space. Good
for you. Making your own baby food.
Yes you know I'll I'll see
about that airline bumping a.
Agree to disagree but I like the fact
that you went out there and stuck up for
the airlines and I think that
said it and all the things right.
Oh I didn't talk about the F1 race mother
fucker did you guys watch it have a
guy now I know after knee is
just absolutely eviscerated
watching racing I hope
you if you were gonna watch a race the
Spanish Grand Prix was a great one.
Lewis Hamilton had the pole.
Sebastian Vettel
I think was yeah it was in the second
position and then Boris Karloff.
Well if I can't keep forgetting
his name fucking Lewis Hamilton's
driving make their his
fucking car caught on fire.
But the first guy the other guy drives
for Ferrari whatever fucking his whatever
his name is Ricky Ricardo.
I can't remember. No.
Daniel Carl drives for Force India.
No he doesn't he drives for Red Bull.
Why don't I just fucking go on and look
up the goddamn names because most guys
don't watch this shit see you don't you
don't know what you guys know as much as
I fucking know. So here's
what happened. All right.
The race starts and.
What's his face. Lewis Hamilton
as always gets a bad fuckin start.
Sebastian Vettel goes around
a battle drives the Ferrari.
Lewis Hamilton's with Mercedes Vettel
is out in front ramming fuckin points he
was ahead he was like 15 points ahead of
some shit and in the old days last year
when I was on watch for a year.
The old days which is Monaco of last
year when I started watching if you would
if you went to the turn first everyone
got it got through the first turn first
in first place drove in and clean air
that was it you won the fucking race
unless you messed up a pit stop or you
your car shit the bed so he gets out in
front
and then his jizz his buddy there.
The other Ferrari guy gets knocked
out of the race OK and they fuck him.
They cut to this kid in the stands
wearing this Ferrari thing where are the
drivers why is it so difficult.
Drivers Here we go here we go.
I should add this already to go I'm
sorry the bike slowing this the fuck down
the Reagan and guy gets knocked right
out of the race and this little fucking
kid they cut to him he's wearing all
Ferrari gear and he's just crying his eyes
out and they're sitting
there going well like.
Vettel still in first place.
Well he must have been a big
Reagan fan over the fuck you say his
name and they shot him twice bawling his
eyes out I could be the kid.
This little was that into racing.
That was really cool.
And later on the driver got knocked out
of the race Ferrari they actually they
brought the kid in.
He took a picture with them and everything
so it had been a good deal although
he probably cried again when
Lewis Hamilton went around him.
But anyways it was a great
race from front to back.
These new fucking tires I guess I have
no idea why they got more gripped as more
passing.
Lewis Hamilton past.
Sebastian Vettel I think on like lap.
Lanes like 20 laps to go which
never happened last year.
The second place guy just could
never get around the first place.
Guy once he was out there.
I don't know.
It was a great race and
then Lewis Hamilton for some
reason was like fucking out
of breath when he was talking as I was
saying because they got the fatter tires
they could pull more GS in like just
physically what the fuck they were going
through. And Lewis Hamilton
didn't have any drinks on board.
I didn't know they had drinks on board.
I'd never even dawned on me but he didn't
want to add any more weight to his car
so he lost like four and a half pounds.
So there you go.
You know that actually you know this
people out here in Hollywood that have
enough money now that the day before they
have to go to like a red carpet event
they're gonna fucking you know
drive around in a fuckin race car.
For three hours so they can drop that
final fucking four and a half pounds I'm
telling you it's gonna happen.
So I believe the next next races in Monaco
I don't know I'm enjoying watching it
now has got me all self-conscious about
talking about it now. When I blame her
then I wasn't prepared to talk about it.
Was there anything else.
I made my little list here.
Those you nerds always wanted
do you read the whole thing.
Pretty much pretty much.
But I make like a setlist a shit and
want to talk to if I can fucking find it.
How is it
I give up.
I FUCKING GIVE UP WITH THIS SHIT.
WHAT DID I have on you.
I don't know what that is.
We'll close this window. This is the most
anticlimactic ending to a podcast ever.
All right.
I said predators Lewis and Hamilton.
Sebastian Vettel.
Daniel Ricardo first time he
was on a podium this year.
Oh he had to give a shout out to force
India still rock in the future whatever
colour that is.
I think that was it.
Oh happy Mother's Day belated Mother's
Day to all the mothers out there at a
great time went to brunch.
Yep that's where I am
right now went to brunch.
My parents came out met their
granddaughter there over
there over the moon love
and she was so cute and was just didn't
cried all the whole meal and then she
got in the car and then that was it.
She friggin had it and was
just crying up a storm.
And but it was it we ended up having a
great day and it came home and I was like
it was crazy you know I've just
finally entered this part of my life.
You know my parents are older.
I got a little one.
I made brunch and I have
no say in the matter.
And you know what it feels good.
I had a great time.
You know we had all kinds of family and
a big crew seven or eight people and we
went to this fucking insane
brunch and everybody threw down
and had like 3000 calories each.
Great conversation great people
it's just it was awesome.
What kinds of pictures
and that type of shit.
And other than the fact that I forgot my
fuckin wallet because I decided to wear
a suit and I was going to be the big
shot picking up the fucking cheque and I
had to go to my parents.
So now now you know when a few days I
take it to the airport I gotta give him
the fucking money back. But OK. It
was embarrassing really embarrassing.
So anyways that was my mother's day.
Go fuck yourselves.
I will check in on you on
Thursday and let's go predators.
And I don't know. I mean I've got
a bunch of friends I you know what.
In Pittsburgh I'm just rooting for extra
hockey at this point Alpo series goes
seven games. I want to be this
little fuckin country Gargoyle.
Shitting on the ducks.
I don't want to fucking do that.
You know why why do I gotta bring out
the predators success and then shit on
Canadiens fans.
You know all their pocket squares are
all soaking wet from them blowing their
noses and crying about losing to the
Rangers. I don't need to do that.
Not to mention I have no bragging rights.
My team that fuckin bounced out you know
I'm going to try to be I'm afraid of
Cutlass for the rest of the Stanley
Cup playoffs. How about that sceptics.
First the Wiz. Ease on down
Ease on down the road tomorrow.
My brain says it could go either way
but my heart says there's no fucking way
there's no way they come in to the
garden even though it's not the garden.
It's the Fleet Center.
At the garden.
Fuckin slash whatever fucking Gossett
Junior whatever other fuckin tags they
have for that thing and I
just don't see them doing it.
I feel like you know what it is.
The sceptics.
They got that sound in their crowd the
same way the Yank old Yankee Stadium had
it you know knowledgeable fans with a
history of success and that can push your
team to fucking when I think they're
going to do it all by the way.
Derek Jeter huh.
I missed it.
I was at brunch I missed it but
that's what a fucking class act ran.
He's such a class act.
He can go into New York and
wing a speech and still kill it.
That's it man.
There are a single numbers
see if I can do it Billy Martin number
one. Number two Derek Jeter number three.
Babe Ruth. Number four I was
fucked this up. That's Garrett.
5 is DiMaggio and six I looked up today
because that's the one I always forgot
but they said it was Joe Torrey but
I thought somebody else had sex.
Sevens Mickey Mantle number eight is
fucking Yogi Bear and somebody else 9 is
Roger Maris 10 is Chris
Chambliss 11 is Gary Sheffield.
I don't know the rest of
them 13 months since 15
last I remember Reggie Jackson
the owner retires there was 44
Bo Diaz with somebody when you were 30
I don't fucking know.
All right that's it.
That's the podcast I will I will check
in on you Thursday and God bless all the
mothers out there
who work with the family back east.
All right I'm done.